l'affaire sera-t-elle pliée dès jeudi à
ce stade en réalité impossible de dire
si les députés voteront la retraite à 64
ans tant l'Assemblée nationale est
divisée sans oublier l'étape de la
commission mixte paritaire chaque camp
en tout cas veut croire à la victoire
celle du gouvernement pour le député
d'Indre-et-Loire Daniel la baronne et
celle à l'inverse de la rue pour le
syndicat CGT romain Delville
autour du projet de loi portant l'âge de
la retraite à 64 ans il y a deux
calendriers le Parlement et le mouvement
social la navette parlementaire touche à
sa fin Assemblée nationale Sénat demain
la commission mixte paritaire jeudi
retour à l'Assemblée ou la majorité
présidentielle aura besoin des voix de
la droite au Sénat ce sont les
répliques qui ont été adoptées très
largement par le Sénat et approuvé par
le gouvernement
donc en bonne logique
j'imagine que les républicains à
l'Assemblée nationale vont pour un très
grand nombre votez ce texte ce qui nous
permettra d'avoir une majorité pour
l'adopter dans la rue demain ce sera la
7e manifestation menée par une inter
syndicale depuis le 19 janvier pour
montrer la contestation d'une retraite à
64 ans 43 admis pour un taux plein selon
la CGT l'augmentation des salaires et en
particulier celui des femmes toujours
moins bien rémunérés que les hommes à
travailler égal engrangeraient des
cotisations sociales capables de
financer des pensions de retraite des 62
ans moi ce que je vois c'est que les
salariés il aurait toujours demandé de
travailler plus longtemps et ça au
minimum jusqu'à 64 ans et ça peut aller
même jusqu'à 67 ans avec les cotisations
sociales qui qui font que quand on
rentre à travailler à 23 ans ça pousse
d'office à 67 ans sans connaître de
période de chômage sans connaître de
période d'arrêt maladie aussi donc moi
je sais pas où ça évolue mais moi j'ai
pas l'impression que ça évolue dans le
bon sens et c'est le texte passe jeudi à
Assemblée nationale le syndicat CGT
n'exclut pas de continuer la lutte dans
la rue pour obtenir l'abrogation du
texte